so if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why
i think a film like the art of
self-defense
is important to me i think just that
type of black comedy
um which has something to say
but it does it with a lot of humor
i think that's something that i
i would want someone to see i just feel
like that's very unique and sort of um
i just really i remember really enjoying
that movie like watching it as like a
movie going like that's a good movie you
know
um
so i'd say something like that i think
riley's really talented
yeah i can't wait to see duel
yeah same it looks awesome looks really
good oh i'm all in um what is actually
the most you've ever prepared for a role
you know
it might even be something like um
this show i know this much is true
um
derek sionfrance
who directed that
we met quite a few times to talk about
this role
joy that i played in the show
um and that was really cool because a
that's a director who cared about every
single
actor and the part they were bringing to
the story but also um
that was the first time i'd
worked in a
new way i worked with um
a woman who actually works with your
dreams and um
you then apply that to the part so that
was like an ongoing
process before actually getting to work
and then sort of
settling into the bones of the character
and and the scene and
the other actors and all of that but um
weirdly that one was
that was like a long build up it was
cool
uh yeah you've obviously made a number
of movies um which is a which is a
project or which is a film that you
think deserves another look like maybe
something that came out and didn't get
like the buzz or
didn't you know what i mean and you want
people to like check it out
well two come to mind and they're both
music movies actually but um
there's a film called all is by my side
which is about jimi hendrix
and andre 3000
played him andre benjamin
and he was
unbelievable
you know he learned how to play the
guitar left-handed and
it was extraordinary like he's a musical
genius and and being there and and
making that film was really special and
i think it came out in a very tiny
release but i remember
sort of
i feel like that movie could have um
she got a little more eyeballs on it or
something i don't know sure uh one of my
last things before getting into outer
range um you have a small
part in v for vendetta very early in
your career
um
and so do you even remember making that
movie and can you watch that now and
realize like that's a really cool and
special film
yeah i haven't gosh i haven't seen it in
years but um i remember really clearly
i remember the wachowskis being so
cool and lovely and
james teague he was so nice um
the snacks
unbelievable
unbelievable because i was like 15
i think around that time
um and yeah it was so fun it was like
the first kind of it was the first movie
i'd ever done so it was like
a movie set and a studio and it really
was sort of what you'd imagine and i
remember finding that really
overwhelming and and really cool i loved
it it's really fun
yeah also uh the wachowskis are geniuses
so that you know early exposure to
brilliance you know what i mean yeah it
was it was cool i remember as well that
was the first time i'd had my hair dyed
so that was fun i was like wow you can
really do stuff in movies
okay
sure um getting into outer range um what
was it about so this this is a cool show
for me because it's a mixture of a few
different things what how did you
actually get told about the material in
terms of
did were you explained like a big arc
and what you're you know what i mean
like real details or like how much if
that makes any sense
yeah um because you're always sent a
pilot script for
shows
um
and so i read that
and of course that was just
you know an eighth of the beast
but
after reading that i really enjoyed it i
spoke to brian watkins the show runner
and zev
um
and they
took me through sort of the idea
um
and they were really reassuring because
i was concerned that autumn
[Music]
uh from what i read on the page might
transpire to be
uh a love interest or a
just a great crazy hippie or something
like that and it was cool talking to
them and sort of understanding the
multi-faceted nature of her and um
what they sort of had dreamt up you know
and being able to trust them with that
um and i could kind of tell by the other
cast they'd assembled what they
were hoping for and um
so it was really from a long discussion
with them and then
you know and they sent like books and
music and
art and all sorts of things to kind of
compile to give you a really good idea
of like the tone and inspiration yeah i
don't i don't want to do spoilers but it
feels like there's a difference between
autumn in the first episode and the
second episode um and i'm i'm sort of
curious is that
like uh does that progression keep going
in every episode where likely you get
more and more about the character
i suppose there's a um there's like an
urgency that starts to
occur
and i think um
[Music]
perhaps because of that
yeah
skins
start to fall away quite rapidly
um
but she's quite a mercurial
person so whether it's
a gear change or whether it's sort of
deep reveal i'm not sure but there's um
she certainly is um
she's kind of like a whirlish she's
constantly going throughout the whole
show for sure she doesn't pause right
the the thing that uh i found with the
first episode and the second episode
both end essentially on like a finale
cliffhanger of a normal season
um which i found you know
it keeps you
you know you want to hit play on the
next episode immediately what was it
like actually reading all these scripts
and seeing
what they were trying to accomplish
yeah um
it was really cool it ended
up somewhere which i couldn't have
predicted and i was
over the moon about
um
so it was just really special and and
the writers they brought on as well like
playwrights and all sorts kind of
contribute and
um
i i yeah and with the directors too you
know because obviously you have
different directors throughout the show
and all of that so that combination with
the writing um
it was really cool it was a very special
thing if i'm honest to be a part of
something which
i really loved
like really loved and loved the brains
behind it
um and the more we got to know each
other as a cast as well
and you get to see
kind of bits and pieces of each other's
work it gets exciting to be like oh my
god noah's gonna get to do that or lou
has to you know that was really cool too
um how actually you've been describing
the show to friends and family
it's difficult because it's it's funny
how someone somewhere said sort of like
western which i guess it has a western
you know hue to it but uh
i i kind of begin by just saying
something
happens and you know it shakes it all up
whatever
still stable life is
is happening the kind of
not white picket fence american family
obviously because they're living on a
ranch but that sort of very
nice
setup
starts to
crumble and uh gets destabilized
something like that you have in the
first two episodes you have a lot of
scenes with josh brolin um and i'm just
curious i read that and i could be wrong
but i read you guys read how harold
pinter together i did like trust
exercises can you sort of talk about how
you prepared to work with josh or uh on
the series
yeah so that wasn't our idea to do those
things
and i went like let you know what let's
read harold pinter together um that was
our director for the pilot and it was a
really cool idea so we uh sat down and
we it was kind of get us out of our
heads and out of the script and and just
try something um but the piece of the
scene we were given was actually very
useful for our characters so we did that
we did some crazy things with a stick
where you have to hold the stick between
your fingertips and then
not break eye contact while moving the
stick around and we both took it very
seriously
um and did not drop the stick but then
after that it was just hanging out
really
you can't beat
that time
you can't beat that sort of just
time spent together
with it with another actor and you know
it only um
embellishes or just supports that
experience because you you just start to
trust and
you know you can you feel free to make
mistakes and
all sorts of stuff the cinematography in
the first two episodes there's some very
interesting camera moves where it's very
deliberate and not a lot of you know
fast cuts can you sort of talk about the
cinematography on the on the series and
maybe what you enjoyed about it
yeah well oh adam he was our
cinematographer on one and two um
and he's just an artist i know it sounds
corny to say but this man is
a pure
pure artist and um i don't know if you
saw last black man in san francisco but
like that was adam's work too and you
know you watch that movie you're like
i just like who shot this film um so
he's just
he's just a master and
what's so cool about working with him
and um we had drew daniels as well who
did waves and euphoria and all that um
they are just
you know they've just got that taken
care of you just have to do your work
and
it really was the collaborative
thing because they watch the rehearsals
obviously and then sort of work with you
to figure out what the best shot is and
they were risk takers as well you know
you'd have pretty wild like the camera
would be on some sort of ramp and then
it was just really fun to see
that rather than like conventional
setups you know that you might expect
yeah i think a lot of people a lot of
the audience
sometimes might not realize the the
shots they're watching but when they're
cool shots it changes completely what
you're feeling and the atmosphere and
you know you know what i mean
absolutely yeah i like add so much and
the way they capture the landscape and
uh
yeah it's all i love the zooms as well
like there's it's just does something
really absurdist and sort of it's just
inherently funny when the camera zooms
in
um so i i loved all that
uh how much have you guys talked about
um i know that this is mentioned as the
first season how much have you talked
about like where this whole thing can go
have you been told like oh we have a
three year plan yeah with in terms of
the show there was no there's been no
such like clinical
plan that's been drawn out
but there are sort of whispers that
people would you know like to go go in
and i think that's based on the last day
of shooting we sort of were all just
like weeping um because we loved each
other a lot but
it's uh it's you know it's unknowable
isn't it sort of what happens with these
types of things
completely i i think that uh i was like
what the f at with the second episode um
i'm not going to obviously get specific
but at the end when there are some
revelations or reveals about
the void if you will i was uh i think i
think people are going to really enjoy
that aspect
yeah i think there's just a um
it feels
feels like the right time
to have a show sort of about time
doesn't it there's something um
uh
there's something really like sinister
and also reassuring about
what the show is sort of
asking i think
yeah i wish i could talk specifics um
anyway listen i gotta wrap there i'm
just gonna say uh i wish you nothing but
the best and enjoy the snow in london
thank you it's nice to see you
you